i
[Música]
a
pequeñas manifestaciones como ésta se
están repitiendo por toda turquía en los
últimos días después de hace tan sólo
unos días la retirada el 1 de julio de
la convención de estambul el primer país
que lo firmó precisamente la cirugía de
recep tayyp erdogán una convención que
busca proteger a las mujeres ante la
violencia machista y los feminicidios
que puedan perpetrar a los padres
maridos hijos o novios de estas mujeres
las turcas se están manifestando por
todo el país para intentar no evitar
esta retirada que ya fue oficializada
este pasado en el julio pero sí intentar
evitar que estos feminicidios sigan
reproduciéndose a un ritmo terrible en
turquía por más de una mujer al día que
en el país se natural llosa asesinada a
manos de algunos sobre su familia o
hombres en general también pasan
asesinatos por las calles con todo el
mundo las turcas intentan evitar así que
esta convención pueda ser abandonada de
una forma como lo hizo turquía con un
decreto firmado por el presente recep
tayyp erdogán una madrugada del 30 de
marzo desde entonces se anunció que
turquía saldrá de esta convención y que
turquía creará dijo el propio presidente
erdogán una convención para proteger a
las mujeres nacional buscando huir
internacional que como decimos turquía
fue la primera en firmar
en argentina desde hace años se
implementan estrategias para intentar
contener la violencia de género una
violencia que se manifiesta de
diferentes maneras los femicidios la
discriminación laboral la inequidad
económica o la agresión verbal en el
país hay ayudas económicas para mujeres
víctimas de violencia de género existen
abogados formados especialmente
fiscalías dedicadas un teléfono de 144
para atención a las víctimas además para
modificar los patrones que reproducen la
violencia de género todos los empleados
del estado deben recibir una
capacitación especial en perspectiva de
género estas políticas oficiales son
consecuencia en muchos casos de las
exigencias de movimientos sociales
feministas que han venido cobrando más y
más fuerza en años recientes en el país
pero a pesar de todas estas iniciativas
en argentina la violencia de género
sigue siendo un gran problema en 2020 en
el país hubo un femicidio cada 35 horas
de acuerdo con un registro que lleva a
la oficina de la mujer de la corte
suprema de justicia de la nación
[Música]
en chile las medidas tomadas para luchar
contra la violencia de género durante la
pandemia parecen no haber funcionado muy
bien según se desprende de un reciente
informe de la contraloría a la dirección
regional metropolitana del servicio
nacional de mujeres y equidad de género
serna make según se desprende de este
informe entre marzo de 2020 y agosto de
2020 en 50 de 53 casos graves no se
utilizó bien o no se derivó o no se
llegó a los mecanismos disponibles por
el sernam para proteger a las mujeres
también se detectaron falencias en el
servicio telefónico que a veces enviaba
whatsapp a estas mujeres una vez
transcurridos los hechos lo que podría
volver a ponerlas en situación de
peligro según se desprende del informe
la institucionalidad en chile necesita
mejorar para brindar real protección a
las mujeres que se encuentran en
situación de riesgo
[Música]